[موسيقى]
هو اتجاه قائم على ممارسة حيث أن
غرف الملح المعالجة بالملح الجاف
وكهوف الملح طوال هذا الوقت كانت موجودة منذ
قرون ، حيث أصبح المسافرون
يمارسون الجلوس في غرفة مليئة بالملح
أكثر سخونة من أي وقت مضى.
المسافرون خاصة مع
الأفراد الذين لديهم
جهاز تنفسي حساس وكذلك المسافرين
الذين قد يكون لديهم القليل من القلق
من القدوم إلى غرفة الملح
والاسترخاء حتى لو كان ذلك لمدة ثلاثين
دقيقة يمكن أن يساعد حقًا عقلك العام
ويسمح لجسمك  التعافي
أو الاستعداد لسفرك وماذا
عن أولئك منا الذين يواجهون أوقاتًا صعبة في
النوم عندما نسافر ، قد يكون الملح الجاف
قادرًا على المساعدة في ذلك - يقول كاري إن
العديد من الأشخاص يحاولون العلاج بالملح على
أمل الحد من الشخير وتوقف
التنفس أثناء النوم أيضًا  نظرًا لأن محاربة
إجهاد الحساسية والجلد الجاف ، فإنه يساعد حقًا
في التخلص من أي من هذا الاحمرار والاحمرار
بهذه الطريقة في بعض الأحيان ، لذا يمكن أن يكون
مهدئًا للغاية عندما تخطو إلى الخطوات الفعلية.
غرفة alt التي تدخلها إلى أرضية
من ملح الهيمالايا السائب وأنت
مغمور في غرفة مغطاة
بالملح على الجدران على الأرض ،
ثم تحصل أيضًا على فوائد
الملح الجاف الذي يتم دفعه بالفعل إلى
الغرفة  أنك في الواقع تستنشق
وتتنفس كرائد أعمال أسافر
كثيرًا ، لذا عندما أسافر
أحاول معرفة ما إذا كانت هناك طريقة يمكنني من خلالها
دمج العلاج بالملح الجاف في تلك
الرحلات ، فأنت لا تعرف أبدًا الأشياء
التي قد تلتقطها كما تعلم  قد
تصاب بالبرد وأن أشياء من هذا النوع
تكون قادرًا على الاستفادة من غرفة الملح
من حيث نظام المناعة لدي والقدرة
على التخلص من أنفاسي ، لديك
الفرصة للجلوس
والحضور والتركيز على
نفسك ورفاهيتك.
انظر أيضًا إلى الأمر على أنه شكل من أشكال
التأمل تعرفه عندما تكون في
مطار ، فأنت في عجلة من أمرك ،
إنه أمر مرهق للغاية ، حيث يقوم الكثير من
الأشخاص بذلك قبل الرحلة ، فهناك
تلك الخاصية الواعية للتواجد في
مساحة هادئة مع القليل  القليل من الوقت
للتنفس والاستقرار في داخلك قبل
أن تفعل شيئًا مرهقًا ،
ستكون تجربة الملح الجاف فريدة من نوعها اعتمادًا
على المكان الذي تذهب
إليه.
مواقع قائمة بذاتها ، لكنك ستبدأ أيضًا
في رؤية قابلية العلاج بالخلايا الجافة قريبًا
في أشكال الأكشاك في
المطارات وغيرها من مناطق حركة المرور العالية جدًا
بالنسبة لي ، إنها مجرد
تجربة كاملة تعرف أنك خارج
العالم المزدحم وأنك في هذا  نوعًا ما
أصغر حجمًا ، يبدو وكأنه شرنقة ، لذا
فهو مزيج منك يعرف الطريقة التي
تشعر بها المساحة ومظهرها وأيضًا
الطريقة التي تبدأ بها
في ملاحظتها في أوروبا على نفسك وجسمك
[الموسيقى]